il semble régner comme un climat de
discorde dans les couloirs du parlement
tunisien dans les rangs de la classe
politique plus que jamais divisée
certaines voix s'élèvent pour réclamer
de nouveaux modes de pouvoir et même une
troisième république
absence de majorité crise
institutionnelle le tout dans un
contexte socio économique fragile pour
certains députés leur semble bien être
changement il y à un climat de tension à
tous les niveaux qui vient s'ajouter à
une crise institutionnelle le tout finit
pas de s'exprimer par une crise
politique à laquelle nous pouvons
ajouter un élément très intéressant est
le dernier qui sont les résultats des
élections d'une ligne 19 qui n'ont pas
permis à aucun parti d'avoir la majorité
et bien si on a un parlement qui est
vérité une crise économique et des
institutions pas présente c'est normal
que nous pouvons avoir une crise
politique dans le pays
la constitution sinon l'avons mais pas
achevé et déjà des plantes de beaucoup
de points
quelle est la solution une nouvelle
constitution un régime présidentiel tout
système politique a des points forts et
faibles
nous n'avons pas de baguette magique
pour nous députés
la chose la plus importante c'est le
citoyen si on le perd de vue
tous ces fonds mais alors comment
expliquer une telle situation
la tunisie est un régime parlementaire
et de ce fait les pouvoirs et les
décisions sont concentrés entre les
mains du parlement
un parlement bien trop divisée qui rend
quasi-impossible vote de lois ou de
réformes
dix ans après la révolution de jasmin le
rendement de l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple et la montée en
force des partis révolutionnaires
conduisent certains appelé à la mise en
place d'une troisième république et au
changement du régime politique 2011
des appels qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
et qui sont quasi permanent surtout
lorsqu'une nouvelle crise politique sur
j
pour ahmad idrissi c'est la révision du
mode de scrutin qui pourrait être une
piste afin de garantir et une majorité
capable de réformer le pays
et d'équilibrer le jeu de pouvoir entre
le parlement et le chef de l'état vous
avez un conflit ouvert aujourd'hui entre
le chef de l'état
et c'est ce noyau de majorité maintenant
s'il ya une pression il y à fort à
parier que le parlement prendra en
charge lui-même les réformes réformer
les institutions c'est à dire deux
choses le partage des pouvoirs entre le
chef de l'état et le parlement et la
modification du mode de scrutin pour
qu'on passe la mode de scrutin à la
représentation proportionnelle vers un
mode de scrutin alors majoritaire à deux
tours probablement voilà ou bien une
combinaison entre ces deux modes de
sorte qu'on puisse dégager une majorité
parlementaire franche et massive qui
peut donner un parti politique
là le tout tous les moyens et toutes là
là toutes les possibilités de pouvoir
gouverner seul ou avec un tout au plus à
notre parti mais pas dans la situation
ne semble il est à peu près cinq parties
il n'aurait même pas à constituer une
véritable majorité
déjà pointée du doigt par l'ancien
président défunt bedji caïd essebsi le
système politique actuel ne peut assurer
le développement et la stabilité du pays
et sans une réforme en profondeur de la
constitution de 2014
l'avenir de la jeune démocratie semble
plus que jamais incertain